foreign
he says this does it ever make sense to
pull from retirement to pay the house
off I'm curious if it would be
acceptable to take out fifty thousand
dollars out of our Roth tsp and pay off
our mortgage my wife and I are debt free
except our mortgage we have 534 000 in
our tsp of which 150 000 is my Roth tsp
I'm 61 and work my wife is 55 and
doesn't work outside the home with my
military retirement VA disability and
federal salary we bring and make around
140k gross a year
we plan on working another three years
or so our mortgage balance is about a
hundred thousand if we stay the course
we will pay it off in five years if we
take the money out of our Roth tsp we
could pay it off in two years
I wouldn't do it
I don't I don't understand why they
wouldn't just stay the course
um
well once you're in retirement if your
nest egg is big enough that you can make
it without I what I don't understand on
this is why we're taking out why he's
not just paying it off
would you well maybe the tax
implications no there's no tax no
because it's all Roth It's all Roth and
so I mean you got a hundred thousand
hundred fifty thousand in the Roth and
if you want to pay off a hundred
thousand dollar mortgage why are we just
cutting it in half are we only putting
50 000 on it doesn't make sense either I
mean either do it or don't paint or get
off the ladder okay so
um if you pay it off you've got four
hundred and fifty thousand
and during the five years you would have
paid it off you can build up some more
retirement in a Roth build it back
that's true
um and you got 450 000 left and you've
got VA disability federal salary
military VA disability and military
retirement so
um would I take a hundred thousand out
of 500 000 and 534 000 and pay it off at
61 years old
that's right on the bubble and here's
why it's right on the bubble okay uh
I if it was 200 000 and you only had a
hundred thousand left I'd say definitely
no okay definitely if it was a million
and you had nine hundred thousand I'd
say yes definitely yes okay so see how
I'm right on the bubble I'm like you
know it's like it leaves a good chunk
but it's not like so if you did this
uh-huh and I probably would I'd probably
just pay the whole thing off I would not
pay off fifty thousand and then you just
take the whole hundred thousand I'd
probably do but the only way you do that
is you pinky swear spit shake you and
your wife look at each other and go we
ain't doing nothing until we put that
hundred thousand back but why wouldn't
they okay I'm playing Devil's Advocate
that's good why wouldn't they because
I'm looking at at the opposite way I'm
like you're making 140k a year why can't
you live on if you really care like that
why can't you live on nothing and get
this thing paid off in two years in two
years I'm with you so that that was kind
of my thought let's see if you do that
you can put it back in two years too
that's true so there's really there's
not a right answer here the bottom line
is both of those answers involve
something he's not putting on here yep
that's right and both of them involve
intensity at way cranked up from where
Michael is right now because he's trying
to trying to play with this 50 000 out
of a hundred why are you doing 50.
that's just yeah yeah you just kind of
yeah come on come on get it whatever it
is you're gonna do go all in and pay the
whole thing off and then bust it and put
it back or just bust it and pay it off
now at 61. busting it wasn't in this
equation at 61 another question does he
need to bust it at all or can he just go
we're just going to pay off our home
keep going keep trucking along keep
investing our 15 keep like can he do
that yeah he could do that does he have
to be intense at this point but
your point is
um either way the thing we're both
feeling in this that we're not that it
took a second to get to the surfaces
it's all lukewarm yeah okay get get
really really hot or really really cold
here and get it whatever it is you're
going to do and so if I woke up in his
shoes which one would I do
I'm probably going to pay it off and I'm
going to put turn on the heat and put
100 000 back in the bank in two years
all right uh but you're going to pay it
off in two years I'm gonna pay it off
using neither one of these answers are
in the dumb column that's right if if it
has that intensity that we were talking
about now if he pulls out that hundred
thousand and he's just you know
Meandering along yeah that that's not
okay